welcome to this video playing gear from
Thailand I guess no Costa Rica
okay then Italian game and at least
that's a game that Nets me some points
of her win it hmm let's see
okay very strange Queen to b3
yeah I don't know don't really know what
this is doing
hmm
can come to e7 to e8 Bishop to e6 maybe
here and then B should be six can also
take and play I know I know I'm opening
up the Fr this wasn't a good idea
I was thinking NYCHA forum I can still
probably do it but it may be this this
this we had Queen b3 move might make
some more sense now if he has some some
way to to do something on them on their
phone it's just playing some more scope
claim
okay I'm not age six as a stretch of
Freccia so I need you this first then 97
neither very ever very solid setup him
long term I have d5 coming so I don't
really think this is anything for what
actually think that it's it's better for
black even with t5 coming maybe can play
d4 or something nice no we're going to
manage to play to age 45
okay just do five for that drawback nope
I don't see it
and that's let's let's gain the space
deform is not helping
I might play d4 himself I should be
ready for that maybe was g5 maybe yeah I
probably maybe I played this advance of
the two on him maybe it was a bit too
early not clear what I should do now and
then he can just take your five great
idea hmm
yeah I advance this too quickly
and Lukas him great I managed to help
Lima sell him really great from a--from
just very simply better position to this
nonsense it's really great not easy to
do it takes some special skill to to
play this this badly and I'm blundering
the look hem black resigns yeah just
it's just really frustrating I mean yeah
you can check this position white has no
palm break here you will never play g5
you will never play b5 it can absolutely
do nothing absolutely nothing and the
only one playing is black with g65 I
just need to time it right it's yeah and
and the computer evaluation is also
completely wrong it gives 0.5 for white
which is completely completely wrong oh
man that's tough yeah the evil is is
wrong because I can I can simply stay
here and do nothing and white will never
ever ever get anything can even put the
knight to f7 and then play King f8 to g8
till hell freezes over and nothing's
going to happen but I have d5 I mean I
have some some porn break I only play
that played at play wrong name the other
thing is that oh this is a cheater
account there's a cheater account quite
obviously yeah I had the suspicion
during the game actually but let's let's
let's check this okay so let's check
how.what five we should be three it's
the first choice of starfish okay they
decide normally moves down eyes it's
it's a substantial resemblance but not
not totally clear it's a sheet around it
looks a lot like one but it's a very
fresh only five minutes and he has had
an enormous score and he had this
typical computer like equal time
distribution so almost eight to ten took
took like four seconds or something
four seconds six seconds three yeah just
look at the white time yeah it's always
playing in a couple of seconds never
really thinking much longer admittedly
I'm doing the same yeah I don't know
it's mostly my own problem here
the main problem was that d5 is mistimed
because of this counter idea a deform
and he it's it's slightly tricky because
he wants to play the form you can go
here probably I should do that but the
problem is I opened this too quickly and
d4 is a problem really
after that I cannot move the upon s d5
is getting weak and this is generating
some pressure on my position it's quite
clear I need to avoid this altogether
not play d5 just need to to stay put you
know it's I think it's equal I mean just
pretty clear that white is not not
doing anything ever unless you kill
yourself okay thanks for watching